another
important question is what happened at
the beginning of the universe
what happened before the big bang and by
the way on that i should say you know
there are some
conjectures uh it's all in principle if
we figure it out if we have a theory of
quantum gravity
it's possible to imagine that we will
figure out how to create a universe in
the laboratory
by irritating the vacuum you might
create
a baby universe and if we do that
it will offer a solution to what
happened before the big bang perhaps the
big bang
emerged from the laboratory of another
civilization so it's like
a baby universes are being born out of
laboratories
and inside the baby universe you have a
civilization that
brings to existence a new baby universe
just like humans right we have babies
and they make babies
so in principle that would solve the
problem of
why there was a big bang and also what
happened before the big bang yes so we
came
our umbilical cord is connected to a
laboratory
of a civilization that produced our
universe once it figured out
quantum gravity you know it's uh it's
it's baby big bang's all the way down
it's
just big bangs all the way up so if we
collect data about how the universe
started we could potentially test
theories of or it can educate us about
how to unify quantum mechanics and
gravity
if we if we get any information about
what happens near the singularity of a
black hole
you know if we yeah if we get a sense of
you know somehow we learn what happens
at this thing
that would educate so there are places
where we can search for
evidence but it's very challenging i
should say and
my point is you know the string theories
they decided that they know
how to approach the problem but they
don't have a single
theory there is a multitude of theories
and it's not
tightly constrained and they cannot make
predictions about
black holes or about the beginning of
the universe so so at the moment i say
we're at
a loss and the the way i feel about this
concept of the theory of everything we
should wait until
we get enough evidence to guide us and
until then you know
there are many important problems that
we can address you know why
why bang our head against the wall on a
problem
for which we have no guidance right we
don't have a good dance partner in terms
of evidence there's not
exactly i mean it'd be interesting just
like you said i mean
the lab is one place to create
universes or black holes but it'd be
fascinating if there's indeed a black
hole in our solar system that you can
interact with so the problem with the
origin of the universe
is all you can do is collect data about
it right you can't interact with it
well you can for example detect
gravitational waves that
emerged from that and you know there is
an effort to do that and that could
potentially tell us something
but um yeah uh it's a challenge and
that's why we're stuck
so i should say despite what physicists
portray
that you know we live through an ex
exceptional
growth in our understanding of the
universe we're actually
pretty much stuck i would say because we
don't know the nature
of the dark matter most of the matter in
the universe we don't know what it is
and we don't know how the universe
started we don't know what happens in
this
in the interior of a black hole
you